Okay, let's talk about
compositing a little bit more.
Now I've got a page here, and what I
want to do is bring out a side nav.
So what I normally do is I have one
layer in memory, and I just redraw
the pixels for the side nav, and
I do that for every frame of animation.
So in the end we have one layer
here with the side nav drawn and
the page content behind it.
Now, the problem with that is that
on every frame, I've been painting.
Instead, what we can do is a better
version of this, where we have
one layer with the page content in,
another layer with the side nav in.
All we then need to do is slide the side
nav over the top of the page, and
we get the same effect,
but without painting.